And I want to help welcome you all to a very special topic today, which is on irrationality. And I've been doing this already now for a pretty long time, as I said, 3.5 years, and I've been reading Jung since 2020. So when the pandemic started, I had a lot of time on my hand and I started reading Jung 20 pages a day.
And even though that I spent now a long, long time, almost 6 years reading about Jung, thinking about Jung, I always find new stuff that's there to explore. And one very interesting topic that very rarely comes up is about irrationality and how Jung sees it.
So we will talk about the concept and ideas from Jung about irrationality, how he sees it, and what he talks about when he talks about irrationality. And to best explain that, I want to talk about the life of Carl Gustav Jung.
And his works are always very intertwined between his life, his personal journey, and the concepts and ideas he had. And we have to think about a very special time in Jung's life. He grew up, he went to school. He studied, he studied psychology, even though that at first he wanted to study, uh, archaeology or medicine.
Well, he studied medicine, but he specialized then in psychology and, uh, started working in what we would call a mental institution where people with very severe psychological problems were. So schizophrenic people, people with psychosis and so on, it was called.
Burghölzli, and he used that to work, but also to explore and do research as a scientist because he was a trained scientist. He had his PhD that he got at university and he was doing their scientific academic research to explore the psyche of human beings.
Because back then, that's roughly 1900, psychology is a completely new science. Not so much stuff is known. It's known that there is something like the psyche, there is a psychology, and there are certain phenomena that are not explained yet.
And the notion comes up that because someone acts weirdly doesn't mean their brain is damaged, but rather you can help people and talk with them through problems and solve these things.
And this is a completely new technology, a new revelation, and it's called the talking cure, pioneered by Sigmund Freud, the very, very, very, very famous psychologist.
And Jung doing research and Freud publishing his works and views on the psyche, on the unconscious as a concept, brings both together because suddenly those experiments that Jung did in Burghölzli and the phenomena he could see but could not explain. He could measure those, but he did not have a framework to make sense of them.
Perfectly makes sense and fitted into psychoanalysis. So they got into contact, they started writing letters, which is, well, the way how to communicate when one person is in Zürich and the other is in Vienna. And they became close friends through that, even though Freud was 20 years older and Jung was very young.
He was in his early 30s, and they immediately form a very big and strong friendship. The first time they talk, it's for 13 hours straight, and they write themselves constantly, and they visited each other and their families. And this goes on, this goes on to a very specific point in time, which is the year 1913.
And there something happens. It becomes clear that Jung has a different view on life and on the psyche and the things he wants to investigate. And that Freud has a very strict and stiff system he set up for understanding humans and how to treat humans in, in therapy. And Jung starts to diverge and Freud feels it.
So their friendship slowly breaks apart. And this is a huge, massive change in the life of Jung. And it defines everything that happens afterwards. Because not only does he give up his friendship with Freud, but rather he ends his academic career. He does not teach anymore.
He basically becomes an outcast. Because he was the crown prince of psychoanalysis. He was the guy who was supposed to bring psychoanalysis to the next generation by him being younger than Freud, who was already 50, in the middle of 50. So it was for him to carry on the torch, but now he, yeah, ran away.
He betrayed Freud, and this caused a lot of psychological problems in Jung and He felt this and he tried to deal with this. And one way how he tried to deal with it was to explore his own psyche.
And this is why I chose as a picture for the event the sandcastles, because it has to do with sandcastles. And here's a very long quote: After the parting of the ways with Freud, a period of inner uncertainty began for me. I lived as if under constant inner pressure.
At times, this became so strong that I had suspected there was some psychic disturbance in myself. Thereupon I said to myself, "Since I know nothing at all, I shall simply do whatever occurs to me." Thus, I consciously submitted myself to the impulses of the unconscious. The first thing that came to the surface was a childhood memory, from perhaps my 10th or 11th year.
At that time, I had a spell of playing passionately with building blocks. I distinctly recalled how I had built little houses and castles. To my astonishment, this memory was accompanied by a good deal of emotion. Aha, I said to myself, there is still life in these things. The small boy is still around and possesses a creative life which I lack.
This moment was a turning point in my fate. But I gave in only after endless resistances and with a sense of resignation. For it was a painful, humiliating experience to realize that there was nothing to be done except play childish games. Nevertheless, I began accumulating suitable stones, gathering them partly from the lake shore and partly from the water.
And I started building cottages, a castle, a whole village. As soon as I was through eating, I began playing, and continued to do so until the patients arrived, and if I was finished with my work early enough in the evening, I went back building, and in the course of this activity my thoughts clarified, and I was able to grasp the fantasies whose presence in myself I dimly felt.
There's a lot of stuff in there, and we have to realize that at this point, Jung is the end of 30. So a grown man, accomplished man, PhD, is playing at the lakeshore, building sandcastles. Why is he doing that? And it foreshadows a lot of the stuff that Jung will go later in his life. He sees himself at this crossroads.
He is incredibly successful in the outside world. He studied, is academically recognized until the break with Freud, of course, has published papers, valid scientific papers, married several children, married the second richest woman in Switzerland. So he had a very, very nice house in Küsnacht at the lake.
And so he achieved everything that one could achieve. And he'd done that through study and research work. Rational thinking and all these things, but he himself felt empty and he felt at a crossroads and he felt lost. So what he did, he turned inwardly and there he recognized certain things coming up in him. And we see two things in here.
The first thing is that he recognizes these things coming up, but he also acts on them and let them happen. What happens after this is what brings us Jung as we know him, because shortly after this, in 1913, his visions start and he's having these visions of Europe drowning in blood and bodies.
And he was thinking he's going crazy because he became overwhelmed by unconscious contents until the First World War started in 1914. And that, Then he became calmer because he was thinking not that he was crazy, having crazy hallucinations. He thought, oh, it's very ironic. Like, I'm a therapist, I'm treating schizophrenic people, and now I get schizophrenia. What an irony.
But he realized he had a kind of prophetic vision. And this is when he, in serious, started to investigate it in psyche. This is when every evening he sat down, went into his fantasies, in his daydreamings, in his dreams. And recorded them in the Black Books. And out of the Black Books, he created The Red Book. And The Red Book is a basis for everything that comes afterwards.
So the Jung we know, and that is famous with his concepts of individuation, of shadow, anima, animus, all these talk about archetypes and symbology and astrology, synchronicity, and so on, comes out of that. This is Jung playing at the lake. At the seashore to build sandcastles. This is the first step.
So what Carl Gustav Jung is embracing there is something that is not really rational, but comes to him. And yeah, brings out the Jung that we know and love. And this is the reason why we are here.
And Jung starts using this term irrational, and he uses it Right after, so the first real book that he wrote after Symbols of Transformation, which causes a breakup with Freud, was Psychological Types. And he worked on that for 9 years.
And this is the basis of typology, and it's a very important book in psychology because the first time that personality gets mapped and categorized. And there he talks about irrational functions. So he talks about that the psyche is structured in a way that we experience the world in different modes or in different ways.
And he sees there four: thinking, feeling, sensation, and intuition. So, and I'm very glad that I have a presentation this time because the first time I talked about this, I had to do it all with words. But what you can see here that they are shaped like a cross and in relation to each other.
And he says thinking and feeling, those are rational functions because we can kind of rationally get to the point, ah, how did we have this thought and what does this thought mean? Same for feeling. Feeling means for him whether I like something or I don't like something, but I can argument why I like something or why I don't like something.
So I can make a rational argument for my feeling, same as for my thinking. But he has this other group, sensation and intuition, where he says those are not rational. Those are irrational because things happen. Things come to me in a way that I cannot really explain. They become an experience.
So if we would say somebody would experience something through all four functions, it would mean first means sensation to say, ah, there is something. Thinking, oh, what is this? And feeling, how do I feel about this? And intuition, oh, what else could it be?
So if you're confronted with something that we do not recognize, we first recognize that we don't recognize it, but think about, oh, could be this, it could be that, that's intuition. And we could think and feel about this then also.
And what he says about these people that have one of those irrational functions in their superior function, so like their most favorite hand, Like everybody has two hands, but we like one hand more and everything we want to do and we encounter, we first do with our strong hand. And this he calls superior function.
Is, if you look at this picture, thinking being superior, that would mean that this type of person would first do things in a thinking way, trying to give names to things. And That would place them in the rational type, but an irrational type would be rather on the sensation and intuition part.
So people that just experience things and take them as a basis of their experience. And this is what this quote from Carl Gustav Jung is about. The irrational type doesn't see or realize by rational feeling or thinking. It always happens to him.
So it is kind of weird to think about, to experience the world in a different way, but we can have this experience. Jung says all of these functions are limited in their own way. Like there's a certain way you can get the thinking, the feeling, the intuition and sensation.
But here important is to understand that when things come to you unstructured without reason, like things popping up, he uses this example of, for example, of a deer in a forest. When it appears, it just pops into your vision. It is just suddenly there. And this is what he means with irrational. For the moment, it's pretty irrational.
We can start thinking about it and having intuition where it's coming from and where it's going, but it just appears. And Jung sees there a way to do this internally, or let's say externally for the deer, but also internally for a thought or a feeling. Something suddenly comes up and the question is, oh, Where is this coming from? What does it mean?
What is the importance of that to us? And Carl Gustav Jung would describe this very strongly as a kind of empiricism.
So we would use this more in an empiricist way to say we, we gather something first, like data or things, just noting them down without a value judgment, without thinking about them, but gathering about things.
He also uses sensation or categorizes sensation and intuition types as perceptive types. And this he calls again irrational by nature because there's not a logic behind it when these things come up. And this is what this quote is about.
That is why I call the perception types irrational by nature, but merely because they subordinate judgment to perception. It would be quite wrong to regard them as unreasonable. It would be truer to say that they are in the highest degree empirical.
They base themselves exclusively on experience, so exclusively that as a rule, their judgment cannot keep pace with their experience. Also Freud's idea is that the dream is rational. I say that it is irrational, that it just happens. A dream walks in like an animal. I may be sitting in the woods and a deer appears.
It is Freud's idea that dreams are prearranged, which I do not agree with. And here we see already a strong split between Jung and Freud, because Jung would say that Freud is a very rational person, a very systematic person. So he looks into the world and he tries to fit things into a system, the system of psychoanalysis.
And Jung wrote very badly about Freudians, saying that they kind of follow a script or pattern to find something inside the psyche of the person. He would say that Freud himself was not so inflexible, but he would say that about Freudians. And Jung was, they're way more open.
Jung would say, okay, there's a lot of things that we do not understand yet, which doesn't mean that they're just a sublimation or like a reduction thing where we say, oh, this is actually about this and that. So Freudian analysis or dream interpretation, let's say, it's pretty famous for that, that everything is kind of a penis or is the incest complex or is sexuality.
And Jung had a big disagreement about this approach to take the world, to take experience and then reduce it down to a system and say like, oh yeah, this is all a facade. This is all not really a thing in itself, but rather, oh, it's a, it's a disguise for something that is hidden.
And this view to see Dreams and experience Dreams is extremely different between Freud And Jung, while Jung would focus on these details to say like, oh, you dream of a fairy godmother. Why do you dream of a fairy godmother? Freud would say, okay, yeah, this is like your mother and likely incest complex. Jung would say, okay, that can't be random.
Like it could be 10,000 things in the world. Why is it a fairy godmother? So we see there already a Jungian approach to focus on details and do this without judgment and without diminishing them. So working very empirically to accept everything as it is first.
Something is there and we cannot argument it away and we cannot really remove ourselves from that. We first have to really record and accept the things as they are. And this goes very much into sensation or intuition. There are things and they are the way they are, and we need to accept that already. And while Freud would say, okay, let's reduce it down.
Let's say this is all facade. This is all a lie. This is a censor trying to trick you and create a wish fulfillment for you. It is okay. There's something natural about this because nature is irrational. It is hard to understand. It's hard to grasp. It's just things happening. And they're happening to us. And we kind of have to accept that.
If we close our eyes to that, it's still happening there. So the Jungian approach is extremely open. And this is why Jung was interested in many, many, many different topics. So the stuff I said before that he's talking about astrology, synchronicity, mythology, religion, occult, Dreams, everything has to do with that. Jung says We have to be kind of irrational about that.
We kind of have to be removed from a system from that and take things as they are first. So this would be also the advice that we would give his students when they want to become therapists. He said, get the best education, get everything you need to know, but as soon as you get to the patient, forget everything.
Take the patient as they are and be not so sure that you already know what the answer is and what this all means. The first reaction should be, okay, I have no idea what this means. And Jung would treat his patients this way, and he would treat his dreams like that. He would say he does not understand his own dreams. It also takes him to figure out what all of this means.
And I want to tell a story here because there's a very, very famous story that Jung often talks about to exemplify this opening up to irrationality and things happening to people. So as I said, he was a therapist. He had patients. He had one patient that was a young woman and she was very tough.
She was very narrow-minded and she was very set in her ways and that created problems for her in her normal life because she was extremely strict mentally. So she kind of figured out the world and everything had to be that way. And of course, things were not that way. And she suffered for that. And Jung tried to open her up and he tried really for a long time.
So they were sitting together, they were talking, but she was taking none of it, that what he was talking about. And it was not until a special day when She said, ah, Dr. Jung, I had this very strange dream last night, and I dreamt of this scarab that visited me in the night.
And she was talking about this dream, and at that point, at the window, there's a clicking, a clicking sound. And Jung goes to the window, opens up the window, catches this bug, hands it to the patient and says, There's your scarab. And this completely blows her mind. This opens her up to weird things happening.
Of dreaming of this bug and then seeing this bug opened her up for this irrationality getting out of her system and being then open for the therapy. And then she could be healed and live her life normally. By the way, on the right side, this is not a scarab. But it looks extremely close to that.
And this is a beetle you can find in Switzerland, but normally they don't go to windows and just click on them. And people talk about scarab dreams. So this is a story that Jung talks about very, very often because this symbolizes for him many, many things. One is of course, is part of irrationality, but the other of synchronicity.
So things happening in the outside world that are matching inner states and have a very specific meaning that is only to reveal to those who experience them.
So what is happening there in the psyche and where Jung says how the psyche acts, we in our consciousness and our ways mentally, in our rational ways, are very much fixed in a kind of system, in a kind of known land, which we say, oh, this is all I know, this is all I can do, and there's nothing else. He would say, no, the psyche is more than that.
Anything you know, like, there's more to know, and you are very much blind to things. So when we have a superior function, when we have our favorite hand, it means we only do it with that hand. And Jung says, no, we have like two hands. On the case of functions, you have four functions. You need to be well-versed in all of them because that's your complete psyche.
This is what you're meant to do and meant to be. You are meant to become a complete human being, and that means to leave the known, well-trodden path and go in the weird and strange. And Jung says the psyche does this by a function called compensation.
So the psyche kind of feels when you're going off too much into one direction and it will pull you down in the other. So for example, two weeks ago, We talked about the movie Scarface, and it was that Tony got completely successful in the external world and rose very, very high, but had no spiritual development. And he suffered for that, and he felt this emptiness.
Even though that he achieved everything that he wanted in the external world, he felt very empty inside. And this feeling comes from the psyche. And Carl Gustav Jung sees this constantly in his patients, in his own experience, that there is something creeping out of the unconscious, trying to bring the person back into balance and make them aware of the things they're missing.
But these things, of course, are disagreeable. Those are strange. This is the right hand. Suddenly you have to brush your teeth with the right hand and you're weirded out by that. Oh, well, I'm left-handed. This is why I say the right hand weirds me out.
But this experience that there are coming unstructured things that do not make sense internally or externally, Jung says not shutting off, but rather accepting them. And there's a quote for that.
For the layman who has done his utmost in the personal and rational sphere of life and yet has found no meaning and no satisfaction there, it is enormously important to be able to enter the sphere of irrational experience. And that's what I meant when I talked about Jung's words and thoughts are very closely related to his own experiences.
Those are following already the meetup group and the podcast for a long time. Every time we talk about life, Jung talks about that life takes a midpoint shift at the end of 30. So exactly like for him. And is there going into the unconscious, into the irrational, into the things that look strange. And why are people afraid of that? This is for the second quote.
Therefore, people are often afraid to look inside, assuming that what they see there will happen in reality. And perceiving, experiencing, those are the irrational functions. Those are the ways to experience the things that not necessarily make sense and are weird and are strange. And if you're not used to that, this is of course an unnerving situation and experience.
And the question is now, of course, like how to deal with it. And I have a quote here for that. If your surroundings begin to be alive and to talk to you, it means madness.
But if you can smile when you meet a toad or squirrel or leaf that says something funny to you, if you don't mention it, don't make a system out of it, then you have had a mighty good morning in the woods. You are very healthy and have a good appetite and will sleep well. You are surrounded by goblins, and your solitude was quite a beautiful garden.
But don't tell it, because then the goblins disappear, and instead you have ghosts. This is a complicated quote. So what we have here is this irrational thing coming up. So like squirrels talking, leaves talking. Jung was surrounded by people who had weird experiences.
So neurotic people, hysteric people, psychotic, schizophrenic people, but also having these experiences himself. What he means by that is being open to be accepting of these things, but treat them in a kind of subjective, personal way.
He said one of the biggest problems he saw with his patients was that they kind of started to lose contact with the the rest of the human race as soon as they had that feeling that they could not explain themselves to others. So when they had, they said loneliness does not come from having no one to talk to, but not being able to express oneself.
And he sees there a big problem in the modern world that these kind of irrational experiences that we had in the past with religion, mythology, and spirituality and so on, did not have a place in the modern world anymore. Like today, maybe more with the internet, social media and so on.
But we're talking now about the world roughly 100 years ago, which was very strict, materialistic, and modern.
And what he means by, because then the goblins disappear and instead you have ghosts, is when you don't see these things as an, let's say, external thing or something outside of you that is happening, coming to you, it suddenly goes inside of you like a ghost. So suddenly these things come invisible, but it does not mean that they're gone.
It's just that you don't see them anymore and have an influence on you. He often draws this comparison that when the, in the past, people talked about ghosts, that they psychologically talked about complexes. So autonomous psychic forces that had an influence on people.
So when people tried to avoid ghosts or get rid of ghosts, that psychologically meant that they were trying to rid themselves of influences from the inside. And he said it's very important for psychic health to kind of being able to put it somewhere else in the world, because if it's not outside in the world, it's inside the psyche, and then you don't really see it that well.
And it has an influence on you there. And the problem with approaching this, because this already sounds a little bit scary, he just states in the second quote, the main fear of the unconscious is that we forget who we are. So it's easy to say like, oh, you have a rational system and a way how to see the world and experience the world and make sense of the world.
Leave it behind. You're suddenly out in the wilderness. You're suddenly in survival mode and you can get also get lost and forget about yourself.
So it has to be kind of mixture between accepting things coming up, trying to integrate them, to kind of bring them into the system, but a kind of higher, more complex system, but also to, yeah, not necessarily get swept away because this is what he saw with his patients with very big psychological problems like psychotic people or schizophrenic people, that they got overwhelmed by the unconscious.
So he says like the fear of the unconscious is completely valid, but it is an interplay between the known and the unknown coming up, exchanging, and being the birthing ground for new things. Same as for him, same as for him opening himself up and starting to play with the sandcastles.
And building those up, getting in touch with these things in the unconscious and kind of surrendering to them. And funnily enough, the things that Jung did in his own practice with his patients was then the same thing. When the people were over 30, the end of 30, he would let them draw.
He would let them write, dance, whatever, express the things they had internally and bring them outside to the world. And also opening up to them and telling them that their worldview is limited and that there's way more in the world, but also inside of them that would help them to make sense of it.
Because this is a kind of starting of a beginning of a journey to be aware of irrational things and to follow them. It's kind of dragon's tail.
You have to find the rest of the dragon still, but this is how Jung started and Now I will show you something which is very, very, very special because I mentioned the letters before of Carl Gustav Jung and Sigmund Freud, and those letters were not to be published for 40 years after the death of Jung, and he died in 1961.
So you can buy the letters, you can check them, and they're super, super interesting because Jung is a huge fanboy to Freud, and both are incredibly cute and sweet to each other. Of course, until the end. And there's a turning point.
There's a turning point in the letters, and there is one passage that Jung writes, and it's showing the, the end of the beginning of Jung's part of first part of life. And what he's writing there to Freud, very excitingly, not really knowing that this was the end of the relationship.
Occultism is another field we shall have to conquer, with the aid of the libido theory, it seems to me. At the moment I am looking into astrology, which seems indispensable for a proper understanding of mythology. There are strange and wondrous things in these lands of darkness. Please don't worry about my wanderings in these infinitudes.
I shall return laden with rich booty for our knowledge of the human psyche. For a while longer, I must intoxicate myself on magic perfumes in order to fathom the secrets that lie hidden in the abyss of the unconscious.
In retrospect, we can say, well, it's, it's a very long while where he stands there because he will stay there for the rest of his life trying to explore the dark parts, the wanderers' dark places of the human psyche to make sense of what it means to be a human being, uh, what it means to live as one, to develop as one.
And this marks a switch because if you read the answer letter from Freud, it's a little bit formal. He's like, oh yeah, that's, that sounds good, son. Don't stay out too late.
And then Jung writes this book, Symbols of Transformation, and sends it to Freud and Freud does not say anything about the book, and Jung then asks, because the book deals with this, it tries to take psychoanalysis and tries to take this into religion, mythology, all these weird and strange things where Freud would say, oh, this is just a father complex.
Why do you deal with religion and art? Art is just a mother complex. What are you doing? This is not necessarily useful. And Jung goes there and says, oh, let's explore the human psyche there. And Freud does not answer. And Jung asks again, why are you not talking about my book? You have not said a single thing about my book.
And it becomes clear that this fundamental shift, this fundamental break between the rational and the irrational, the stiff static system and the open sprawling world of the unconscious is happening. And Jung realizes he needs to separate and get out of the relationship with Freud, get out of psychoanalysis in an official way, and yeah, embrace his own journey.
And this journey then started with building the sandcastles, writing the Black Books, writing The Red Book, and doing all the amazing works that he did afterwards. And he moved from what is in the beginning was a kind of mythbuster when he talked about the occult saying, oh, it's all the unconscious.
And he sounds a lot like Freud when he talks about these things, like, oh, it's all the unconscious happening. And You can kind of reduce it down. He becomes later kind of full-on mystic. So he does the whole development, the whole journey, and he does it through his own experiences, his own doing, and his openness to these irrational things.
And this is what he talks about when he says individuation is about doing. It is about materializing things in the external world, bringing things out of the unconscious and processing them there and having them there to see them, to experience them. And do this step by step.
And in the end, you also can become a world-renowned Swiss psychologist. And yeah, this would conclude my presentation for this topic on irrationality. Jung talked about when he talked about irrationality and how it all came together in his life, his work, and yeah, what we can kind of learn from that. And I want to thank you for your time and attention.
And now I'm really, really curious how the discussion part will be. So thank you.